once director or actor reach out to me I
would do a live cast and taking lots of
photographs of actor then start to do a
design and basically like when special
effects makeup involved I would start a
sculpture on a live cast and decide what
kind of prosthetic will be necessary to
turn this actor into the character and
so after that I would do a test makeup
and maybe several times as a designer I
will make the makeup ready to delivered
on set and I will hand over to the
makeup artist to apply on application
every day for the filming so difference
between a beauty makeup in special
effects makeup is beauty is kind of
correction makeup or beauty makeup to
apply own actor but special effects
makeup we will create a prosthetic to
put on actor to change the look or
character of the actors we used a
platinum cured silicone which is soft
and really soft it's like a levy that
it's almost like a skin after I sculpted
the piece and I made a mode of each
sections and pour the silicone into the
mode and cast prosthetic pieces and good
only actor of course this person I will
be working with will be a question
designer because for example like a
darkest hour he had to have a body suits
to make his body shape look like a
cha-cha and so it was really important
because all suits was a custom-made and
tailor made and they had to be fit
really well on the body suits and also
body suits have to accommodate the
weight of the suits so we had to walk
with Jack rain really close to each
other and figure out what would be the
best shape and density of the body suit
still fit with suits they made once the
piece is applied it will be ruined after
the removal every day so we had to have
a new sets every day to a preowned actor
so David - key and Lucie civic did
application on set and it took about 3
hours and 15 minutes
every day we will read a script and talk
to the director or producer or sometimes
production designer and to figure out
what they need and from there it's like
whenever we create something like you
know like a fantastic creature or aliens
nobody knows what they look like and but
it's very important to have a have
elements of animals or insect in the
nature that people know about it because
normal human to recognize if it's alive
or not they have they have to have a
kind of idea or knowledge of other
animal that they knew but it's already
embedded in their brain to kind of
recognize okay this is make sense we can
do something needy like I made up but
sometimes it doesn't linger to the
audience so we have to design each
character based on what we know Gary
didn't look like a charger at all and
the proportion of the face facial
structure is quite different so I will
study Chargers face to try to put
essence of charger on a Gary's face but
I cannot change the position of the
Gary's eyes too much to the Churchill so
there will be a lot of translation of
myself to try to make him look like
Churchill at the same time that it
shouldn't be look at them he is wearing
a mask because it's a makeup and he has
to act through it so important part is
to figure out the balance of what to put
on and what's not to do there was a lot
of trial error but we figured out good
balance to make everybody understand he
is a Churchill and make Gary easy to act
through it that's a really difficult and
sometimes we don't know until actually
we try to put on pathetic pieces on your
actor because some actor has different
skin conditions and in this case Gary is
you know like a before 60 years old and
his skin is kind of a little more
straight here
young people so we had to figure out
where to leave himself on but still
walks as make him look at the charger so
we try to avoid any kind of prosthetic
go into the his eyelid and Alan dies
because it's the skins really soft so
it's really kept case by sick case if
this makeup didn't work that they didn't
they were not going to make the film so
Gary came to me he told me that if I'm
doing a design he would take this role
if not he's not gonna do that so it's
really at the beginning because if
there's no charger there's no fear it's
uh you know I was quite fortunate that
we involve this film at a really deep at
the bidding of the whole production
especially like a likeness makeup is
really hard and also especially someone
like very common face or a very famous
face because especially can you bet UK
people like everybody knows what charger
look like my main focus and challenge
was to make the makeup look convincing
enough for people to understand okay
they're looking at Chacho it was really
difficult to set on the point because
until the makeup is applied on the actor
I don't know how Gary will act through
the makeup too so that was a challenge
to figure out to have a good balance you
know not too much and not too late and
it's a good balance to convince
everybody that okay they are looking at
the charger of course you know Gary's
acting was amazing so without that make
up this one
[Music]
[Music]